MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Hello.
JOSH SASSOON: Hi.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Oh, hi.
Today we are talking
about YouTube and design.
YouTube's grown tremendously
over the last nine years
and now has a global
community of users.
And that is a really
interesting design problem.
JOSH SASSOON: I mean, if you're
going to have a problem, that's
a good kind of problem
to have, right?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Oh.
Yes.
But it presents a challenge.
And that challenge
is, how do you
design a product that
looks and feels consistent
when it means something
different to everyone
who uses it?
Most brands have a
pretty clear idea
of how they want
to be represented.
But at YouTube, our challenge
is that YouTube represents
everything from delightful
and silly content
to serious and sensitive stuff.
JOSH SASSOON: That sounds
like a pretty crazy challenge.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Exactly.
Exactly.
JOSH SASSOON: So
why don't we share
the story of how we
took on that challenge
and captured YouTube's brand.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
Sounds good to me.
Everybody, this is Josh and he's
a product designer at YouTube.
JOSH SASSOON: Hi.
And this is Michael.
He's a marketing designer.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
We work together on YouTube's
User Experience Team.
And, Josh, let's
tell these folks
what they can expect
in this video.
JOSH SASSOON: Sounds
like a good plan.
So in the next few minutes we're
going to cover a few things.
The first is how a traditional
style guide can actually
be something much, much
more than a style guide.
The second is understanding
your brand's identity
through its community of users.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
And then we can wrap up
with some tips
and tricks for how
you can use this
in your own work.
JOSH SASSOON: Cool.
So we represent a
collaboration between UX design
and marketing.
And we actually started building
a traditional style guide.
And then we decided
that we needed
to do something different.
And we ended up
with something much,
much more useful to our team.
So here is just
one page from what
the style guide looks like.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Right.
The guide we created
lets teams at YouTube jam
together on product
design and content
creation by speaking
a common language.
We can't go through the
entire resource in this video,
but we're going to share some
of the content and process that
went into turning YouTube style
guide into a thought guide.
JOSH SASSOON: A thought guide?
What's a thought guide?
MICHAEL AUSTIN
SUI: Well, what do
you think I'm
thinking right now?
JOSH SASSOON: What are
you thinking right now?
I think you're thinking that
when YouTube first started,
it was a video dating site.
Am I right?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
You are right.
And that blows my
mind every time.
I love it.
Good job.
JOSH SASSOON: So
since then the site
has evolved into an entire
service-- a huge service.
And the video content on the
service has grown up, too.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
YouTube is a platform
for community movements, like
It Gets Better Project, memes--
like the Harlem Shake--
and serious subjects--
like political uprisings
captured on mobile phones.
JOSH SASSOON: And obviously
YouTube gets all of its content
from its users.
So that means that our users are
designing our product with us.
So why wouldn't a style
guide actually reflect that?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Exactly
what I was thinking.
So we think it's way cooler
to design with our community
than for our community.
I mean, not that we're not
designing for our users.
We are.
But I mean with them.
We feel like family--
like the Brady Bunch.
JOSH SASSOON: But that presents
a second question, doesn't it?
Who makes up
YouTube's community?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
Well, you might
think it's just people
watching videos.
But it's more complex than that.
JOSH SASSOON: So
complex, actually,
that we spent about
a year doing research
with users to learn
how they interact with
and relate to YouTube's brand.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
Here's some of that research.
Here is a page
from a diary study.
And that looks like
somebody using their tablet
on the toilet.
Is that accurate?
JOSH SASSOON: I'm afraid it is.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
Well, that's fantastic.
Because we can use that.
We like data.
Sometimes research
and analytics are
used to solve a really
specific problem,
like how to improve
task completion
or click-through rates.
JOSH SASSOON: But
we're actually curious
about larger communities and
their needs on our platform.
Not just a specific persona.
And not just the people
that are watching videos.
So going back to
that question, who
really is everyone on YouTube?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Right.
The YouTube community is
really complex and diverse.
There's a lot of
people viewing videos.
But that's not everyone.
There's also people making
really interesting content,
creating original videos,
vlogs, shows, music.
All of that stuff.
JOSH SASSOON: Yeah, and
actually another thing
that we found interesting is
that advertisers were uploading
amazing content and
collaborating with our creators
to make commercials and ads
that people really love to watch
and actually wanted to share.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Right.
So the research and digging
into experiments, data,
and YouTube's history
revealed that there's
real tribes of people
collaborating on the platform.
And that information is so much
more interesting and valuable
than it is for us
to invent personas
or to design for just
one kind of user.
JOSH SASSOON: Yeah.
So a style guide
is usually there
to document a brand
in one direction.
It's like a photo
from one perspective.
And we wanted something a
little bit more dynamic.
Something that was
more like a mirror
that reflected principles
back on the community.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Right.
So if we had a
mirror like that we
could use it to determine the
success of our design solutions
or campaign creative.
The new metric
being authenticity.
JOSH SASSOON: And
it was that idea
that started to turn our style
guide into more of a thought
guide.
And it began by curating words
that described our brand that
would reflect the personality
of YouTube's tribes.
And then it actually
guided product design.
And it also helped
craft marketing efforts.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
The words.
The words--
JOSH SASSOON: The words.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
--are connected.
Human, spirit, and simple.
JOSH SASSOON: Awesome.
Words!
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Woo-hoo!
JOSH SASSOON: Words!
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Words.
JOSH SASSOON: So we
have these words.
What we do with these words?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Right.
Right.
OK.
So words are good.
Words are good.
They're well-meaning words, but
we need actionable principles
that we can actually work with.
So let's take connected
as an example.
We've identified our tribes--
creators, advertisers, viewers.
And individually--
unconnected-- they're
just floating out there in
space like little stars.
But say we do something.
We create a product
or an experience.
And we try to solve two of their
needs and connect those groups.
Well, that's great because
now we've got a line.
And that's good.
But you still got one
floating out there.
JOSH SASSOON: But what if we
actually connected all three
and we made a consolation
which conveniently
looks like a play button?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Gorgeous.
JOSH SASSOON: Whenever you
have three points connecting
your community together
you can actually
triangulate your position.
You know where you are.
You know who you are.
And you know where
you're going to go next.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
Exactly.
And chances are if
you've done all those
and you've connected
them, you're
probably making work that meets
the needs of more user tribes.
And that's a good thing.
So we shifted the way
that we evaluate our work
by adding the metric
of connectedness, too.
So we aim for beautiful
constellations, not just
solutions that serve one group.
The more the merrier.
JOSH SASSOON: Yeah.
And I think if we look back
this principle is actually
happening already on YouTube.
We had lots of advertisers
that were already
working with creators to
create great commercials
and ads for users.
So a lot of this was
already happening.
And all we did on our end was
we started observing this.
And then we assembled
a team of designers
from product and
marketing all together.
And we started to think
about the brand voice end
to end on YouTube and
came up with those words.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
And those words-- again,
connected, human, spirited,
simple-- they became
principles that
helped us create
a common language.
That was a real
thing that evolved.
A common language for
product and marketing
to collaborate together.
So let's look at
some of the ways we
work to deliver on those
attributes and principles.
What comes to mind is
the YouTube Music Awards.
That's a way that we ran
with the idea of connected.
So we streamed a live event from
Seoul, Moscow, London, Rio, New
York, so that the entire
world could celebrate
music on YouTube
at the same time.
JOSH SASSOON: Very cool.
And, actually, on
the product side,
I think I have a good
example of connected.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Oh.
All right.
Let me hear it.
JOSH SASSOON: So we discovered
that creators really
wanted to connect more
with their viewers.
And we built this tool that
lets those creators see
who their top fans are.
And now they can
actually reach out
to their most
engaged subscribers
and start a conversation
with them or just say thanks.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: I love that.
Humans connecting
with other humans.
JOSH SASSOON: Yeah.
Speaking of human--
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Speaking
of human-- let's talk
about LGBT creators on YouTube
who made it a safe space
to come out and
speak their minds.
We thought that was so
awesome that we wanted
to make a video celebrating
their work and those moments.
So we did.
And then we asked people in
that video to upload their own
and join in using the
hashtag proud to love.
And they did.
It was an awesome
response and so
nice to connect with the
community in that way.
JOSH SASSOON: And now
there's Proud to Play, right?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes,
there's Proud to Play, too.
You can search for
that video on YouTube.
It's lovely.
JOSH SASSOON: Cool.
MICHAEL AUSTIN
SUI: You know what?
Tell them about that secret
Harlem Shake Easter egg
because that is a good
example of spirited, I think.
JOSH SASSOON: Yeah.
It's very spirited.
So if you go to YouTube and you
type in "do the Harlem shake"
into the search field, the site
actually does the Harlem Shake.
It's pretty cool.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: I love that.
So this is the still image.
You really have
to go to the site
to try it and see
it for yourself.
It's awesome.
But we wanted to
express our spirit just
like the original creators
of the Harlem Shake
and everybody who
joined in with them.
JOSH SASSOON: Cool.
So we also want YouTube to
feel simple and easy to use.
It's one of our biggest
ongoing efforts.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI:
Yup, that is true.
And it's one of the hardest.
One of the ways we tried to
solve that was with an app
called YouTube Capture.
And it made it a lot
simpler to upload videos
to YouTube from your iPhone.
JOSH SASSOON: I think
the original flow
took almost a dozen steps.
And we were able to reduce
it down to just two steps
and also include editing and
enhancement capabilities.
That's pretty simple.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Love that.
Amazing.
So I think when we look
back at all these things,
one of the things we learned
was that no matter what we're
doing-- whether it's an app or
campaign creative-- we can find
ways to embody the brand
attributes in our work.
JOSH SASSOON: And depending
on the specific user
tribe or the context, we
can dial those attributes
up or down.
So they're really flexible.
And I think now's
a good time that we
show a chart so this
presentation actually
feels official.
You have to have a chart.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes, that
would make this very official.
All right.
I think we've got a chart.
And it's called "Find
the Right Balance".
Here it is.
JOSH SASSOON: So for
a product feature,
we look for solutions that
feel connected and simple
predominately.
And that's the blue and
the purple on this chart.
And then we throw in a
dash of spirited and human.
We always have all four
attributes present.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yes.
So take the marketing campaign.
All four are present again.
But we want a super sized
helping of spirited and human.
That's the yellow and the
red pieces of the pie.
And then connected
and simple are there,
but they might be side dishes,
but they're still at the table.
JOSH SASSOON: Right.
So these are actionable
brand principles.
That's awesome.
Now what do you think
we should do next?
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: I think
we should wrap this video up
with a bulleted
list of takeaways.
JOSH SASSOON: Oh my gosh.
You read my mind.
I love bulleted lists.
MICHAEL AUSTIN
SUI: Mind reading.
JOSH SASSOON: The best way
to wrap up a presentation.
So when you're designing
your own thought guide,
here's some things
that we learned
that we wanted to
share with you.
The first thing is
it's hard to make
good decisions with
incomplete date
or just one kind of persona.
So if you can
research real users,
and especially think about
entire tribes of users,
dig into that and
identify your community.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Nice.
Love that.
All right.
So once you've got your
community identified--
those people are full of
passion and personality.
So why not look to
them to help define
your product and your brand.
JOSH SASSOON: And next if you've
identified your community it's
way way, way more fun to design
with them instead of just
for them.
So engage with the
tribes on your platform
as often as you can.
Talk to your users
and communities.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: OK.
Love that.
And when it comes
to brand attributes,
I've got a tip for you.
Are you ready?
JOSH SASSOON: Yes.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: OK.
So it's flex and fit.
So choose words that are
flexible in their definition
yet specific enough to
actually work and be useful.
And then once you get them, you
can dial them up or dial them
down depending on the context
of your project or your work
or the problem you're
trying to solve.
JOSH SASSOON: Cool.
And last but not least, think
principles before pixels.
Stay true to your community
by turning those brand
attributes into
actionable principles
that you measure all of
your design work against.
A thought guide can actually
help any size company--
large or small-- with
any type of community
make better decisions.
It's been a huge change for
us in how we design and work.
MICHAEL AUSTIN SUI: Yeah.
Definitely.
So thank you guys for watching.
Thank you for your time.
Check out some of the
videos we went over
and shared today on youtube.com.
That's the website.
And we hope you have
a great, great I/O.